scattered in Florida YouTube's favorite
show that's right they have a lot of
food they like my videos today we're
giving away an Xbox and my Pokemon
collection just make sure you leave a
like on this video smash the like and a
bell ring and then you could win all of
these three items at some point all you
have to do is not laugh in this video
guys the roll is simple you'll laugh
you'll lose it's good to do flow to do
money what do you think Donald Trump
needs to do to come out on top well on
the character issue the public you know
two-thirds or more of the public knows
that Hillary Clinton's a liar she can't
be trusted and now the two faces of
Hillary Clinton are coming out the fact
through WikiLeaks that she says one
thing oh no all right let's see if we
can get congressman Collins back
obviously we just lost the satellite
feed that sucks
what I'm sorry what this is real oh no
god bad damn oh what a bummer we just
lost the satellite feed just like that
happens uh-huh happens at the worst
times isn't it oh no we do monetize all
the pretty priced videos that sucks
oh no all these videos lost all these
revenue we're gonna try our best to get
it back in time
that sucks
oh my god give it back to him oh my god
thank you
she says goddamn that was amazing
literally giving up on dice got the flu
right in case it was an obvious just
letting you know I am aware okay I know
what I'm doing I just like to have fun
plus I would like to win the Pokemon
collection that's right I'm joining my
own giveaway all you have to do is leave
a like hit the bell button and tell your
mother you love her another Russian is
happening read everybody the top of
comedy in Russia you heard about this
bread you ever seen a bright hilarious
I never seen anything funnier than a
loaf of bread that's all you need just
give two grown men and a loaf of bread
and they'll they'll never stop laughing
[Music]
[Laughter]
why am i laughing I'm so confused what
is happening if someone knows I would
explain this one to me thank you
thank you very much Gabe RTL his first
hornworms you know what if he just makes
friends live it trying to kill it stop
laughing this is really dramatic
[Music]
Mario it's not a paintbrush he's not a
very good painter though well now I want
to get what just you know boyo this is
the problem last a couple of your life
you loose it ago we had an Hedgehog and
now we ended up with a hedgehog so no no
I'm gonna say no on that one oh my god
this game game I'm so glad I'm done with
this game
how long has he been playing
is that 12 hours no that car sucks
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh-ho-ho oh he's losing it
[Music]
we're making out with a chair
[Applause]
let's everybody they do exist
[Laughter]
it's a Nazi pug dude we found him he
escaped from jail oh my god oh this
gives me hope and faith because I
realize I'm not the most awkward person
in public Jesus Christ dude I'll link
down in the description that's
incredible
thank you guys for watching another
episode of scare the little ready my man
have you guys joined the give away make
sure promise it's not a fake giveaway
like all these other youtubers are doing
this is legit authentic giveaway I want
to give back to my fans which is one of
you by showing you know by being so
grateful one of you will get one thing
because I want to give back to all of
you by giving to one which I won't give
for you this is a scam I'm telling you
it's a scam think I'm gonna give away my
Pokemon collection what are you nuts
get out of here get out of it I'm saying
literally get out the video is over
goodbye everybody leave a like if you
Scott Daly we like who flora and goodbye
sayonara
it's been great why do I keep going can
I end the video now thank you
oh god it's still going okay just gonna
click stop